hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to the
edition of ask Evan today I'm going to
be breaking down a website from one of
our viewers his name is Alan and he's
putting together new sales training
program for entrepreneurs how to improve
their sales and has a survey that he
wanted me to check out and give some
advice on so let's load up the survey
and see what he has to say here so it's
the most advanced sales training for
entrepreneurs and small business owners
I'm putting together new sales training
program for small business owners
entrepreneurs how to effectively
research sales goals to give you new
ways of getting more clients unless I
massage your poor develop trust
discovers there's buying strategies
limit resistant for bright objective
prospect so those where deals foster
increased bottom line and so on the
feedback being valuable and helped me
decide how and when to deliver the sales
training program thanks in advance for
help okay and then questions so I don't
think a lot about referring to fill this
survey yeah to be honest unless they
know you what I would recommend doing
here is you need a better hook the most
advanced sales training for
entrepreneurs of small business owners
is an old k headline but it doesn't
really grab me I don't know if
entrepreneurs to Center need the most
advanced I don't that's a really big
pain point or not and entrepreneurs and
small business owners is really the same
thing so I pick one and reduce you know
the amount of text that you have to read
so you're limiting non-essential words
here and tap into their pain a little
bit more like most entrepreneurs a lot
of them I don't know what what kind of
you know content you're gonna be
covering here but you talk about sales a
lot of people are afraid of rejection
that's one of the biggest things are
afraid to pick up the phone afraid to
talk to people afraid to settle at their
comfort zone especially a lot of
introverted entrepreneurs and if you
could speak to their fear and their pain
more and help them overcome that I think
you have a much more valuable
proposition here that people would be
more willing to go through with you so
you know getting more clients in less
time
is okay you know without your pouring
trust from the first contact okay like
are these the main pain points is not
gonna make me jump out of my chair and
want to sign up with you probably not so
I'd improve the headline and I prove the
content here to be a little bit more
attention grabbing I'd also maybe have a
little bit more about who you are and
what you're really good at um I know
you're active in our form so we've seen
you there but if I'm just lying on this
page or if you want people to fill it
out they get an email or an email from a
friend there's no information on who you
are there's no picture there's no
testimonial so you want to establish
some credibility here to you know make
me think hey this guy really knows what
he's doing and it's worth my time to
learn a little bit more about what he's
all about so I definitely put a picture
testimonials or video introduction
something like that on top of improving
the headline and the content here just
to make it more of a hook finally I'd
also put some kind of incentive why
should people fill this out do they get
some kind of bonus or download or they
get you know some kind of free video
training from you or you know some
something else like what what's the hook
why should I fill this out again besides
you know somebody knowing you why would
they fill this out and if you want to be
able to get some good data from this you
want to be able to branch out beyond
people who know you because they're
gonna be pretty friendly right they're
gonna say yeah this is definitely needed
and here's how much I would spend and
probably be too optimistic where if
you're being able to reach out beyond to
people who don't know you then you might
get a more honest feedback about the
program that you're offering
so regardless of that let's look at the
question so if this is it of interest
okay yes or no tell us some of our live
location okay delivery schedule cost
when should we hold the training what's
your number one challenge okay so these
are some you know questions not too many
you're not collecting contact
informations and so if somebody fills
this out and says yeah I'm interested
I'm in downtown Toronto or I wanted once
a week and I'm willing to pay fifteen
hundred bucks
my biggest question burning right now is
X Y Z you know who is this person who is
a potential lead for you right you want
to capture that so that you can quickly
follow up with them and you know offer
your one-on-one coaching or sign them up
into some kind of one of your seminars
of teleseminars as much as possible you
want to create your lead generation
system so people can can you know get in
your funnel and you can follow up with
them I think that would be definitely
helpful for you so just a few ideas I'm
assuming you just sent this to a few
people that you know and are hoping to
get some feedback but I think if you
improve the headline improve the
messaging put the picture in testimonial
maybe even a video had some kind of
bonus for people to get if they filled
it out and also has some way to follow
up with people then I think you get much
more accurate results from a wider data
set and hopefully give you better a
better understanding of what people are
interested in so that when you do launch
your your sessions they'll be awesome
and filled up and you'll be able to help
a lot of entrepreneurs so hopefully that
helps for those of you watching if you
like the video please give it a thumbs
up it always makes me want to do more of
these for you and if you have a comment
about this website or you have a
question about your business I'd love to
be able to try to answer for you if you
want to leave it in the comment section
below so thank you and we'll see you on
the next episode
you